في النقاش حول هذا الموضوع سالنا الناس في
الاردن ما السؤال الذي تعتقد انه يجب
تطرحه انت في مقابله العمل خلونا نشوف
الاجابات
[موسيقى]
اول سؤال ممكن اطرحه الراتب بضمان
ممكن اسالهم كمان اذا ممكن اجرب الشغل
مثلا شهر انه جربوني واجربهم ممكن ما
ارتاح الشغل هل ممكن اني مثلا معاكم كمان
عشر سنين نفترض مثلا انه يكون في حوافز
مثلا ترقيات زياده رواتب بدي اسال اول اشي
عن طبيعه الشغل شو المحفزات اللي عندهم
التامينات اللي راح يقدم لي اياهم مثلا
الرواتب اللي
راح يعطيني من هالشغله الترقيات
[موسيقى]
الحوافز اللي راح يعطوها
التامينات اللي ممكن الواحد ياخذها من
الوظيفه يعني
نظام الترقيات ونظام العلاوات مثلا اذا في
مكافات هل يوجد تامين يعني في تامين ما في
تامين في مكافات بعد التقاعد ما في مكافات
التقاعد بس
[موسيقى]
في اكثر من سؤال يعني مثلا قديش الراتب
سجلوا الضمان ولا لا كم عدد الساعات
بطلبوا عدم محكوميه اشياء زي هيك الوقت
الوقت يعني ضروري وملحه انه الانسان
يستطيع من خلال يوفق بين عمله فيها وايضا
اسرته والمهام الاخرى
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات